from the daily wire uh reading out says
california gubernatorial candidate
caitlyn jenner slammed
late night host jimmy kimmel after he
called jenner trump in a wig
during his show on thursday night kimmel
celebrated the end of keeping up with
kardashians which ran for 20 seasons
across 14 years and inspired 10
spin-offs
10 spin-offs of keeping up with the
kardashians
i didn't even know there was one there's
10.
my lord kimmel said anyway i'm not gonna
repeat his jokes cause it's
not even really funny but he then he
then he made a joke that uh
caitlyn jenner is donald trump in a wig
and then there was some outrage
about that but but not from the left of
course it was from the right
and jenner called out kimmel the left
and the lgbt community
on twitter on friday he tweeted quote
last night jimmy kimmel called me donald
trump with a wig
he obviously believes that trans women
are simply men with wigs on
well where's the outrage from the left
or lgbt community being woke must be
optional if you're a democrat
and of course there as i said plenty of
people on the right
jump jumping on this bandwagon and
saying oh where where's this is
transphobia where where's the outrage
from the left
where's the outrage uh it and
yes okay it it is hypocrisy
of course it is we we all understand
that
if jimmy kimmel had made this joke about
any other trans person
um that i can even think of because all
the other ones that come to mind are
on the left uh any other you know
prominent trans person in in the public
eye or
not problematic if he had chosen any
other target for that joke
who's transgender and it's not caitlyn
jenner
yes there would be there would be
tremendous outrage on the left and he
would be
well the joke never would have been made
in the first place so we don't have to
think about it but if somehow it was
then there'd be tremendous outrage and
he'd be forced to issue an apology and
all the rest of it
calling calling a a a quote-unquote
trans woman
a man in a wig yes from the left in
every other circumstance
they're gonna call that blatant
transphobia and it's unacceptable and
it's probably a hate crime
however um
so does that mean that we on the right
should jump on this bandwagon and say
hey this is transphobia
we're outraged by it why aren't you
you guys are the real transphobes should
we be doing that should we do that whole
routine
the answer is no we shouldn't and i'll
tell you why two reasons number one
and this is something we all need to try
to understand and keep in mind
the left they don't care about their
hypocrisy
not only do they not care about it but
it's the point
the hypocrisy is the point
because that shows their cultural power
what they're saying is
we make the rules yeah obviously the
rules don't apply to us like they do to
you
thanks for noticing we're the ones in
charge
yeah clearly we don't care in general
about quote unquote transphobia
this is a this is a tool that we use to
bludgeon our opponents
you're our opponents we're not going to
bludgeon ourselves with the tool
that's the left they will all but come
out and say that
it's clearly their strategy so by
pointing out
by merely pointing out the hypocrisy in
this way it doesn't achieve much because
it yeah we all know it but they know it
too
and so what's the point the hypocrisy is
the point
because it's all about power
that's the first problem with the
democrats or the real transphobe thing
the second is that in order to
criticize the left on their own
grounds right by throwing their own
labels back at them
and i understand the temptation to do
this because you're saying uh well
yeah we're gonna we're gonna make them
take a dose of their own medicine we're
gonna
hold them to their own standard and all
this kind of stuff the problem
is that to criticize them on their terms
not only is it ineffectual because they
don't care
but also it requires you to adopt their
presuppositions
it it it by criticizing them on their
terms they've already won
because you're agreeing with them
so the left they can when they hear when
they hear people on the right
non-ironically using the term
transphobia
the left they can sit back and say well
our work here is done
you suckers you think when you start
calling them transphobes they're
they're they're cowering in fear oh no
they're calling us transphobes what will
we do
we've been defeated we've been bested at
our own game oh drat
we would have got away with it too
if not for you darn kids no
not at all they're saying okay thank you
thanks for agreeing with us
by using a term like transphobia you're
agreeing with them you're seeding the
point
you're surrendering the ground you're
adopting their philosophical
presupposition
presuppositions
on the right what we should know is that
first of all transphobia is not a thing
i'm not going to accuse anyone of being
a transphobe that's not a thing
phobe is fear no one's afraid of trans
people
the people like myself who are critical
of the concept
of transgenderism it's not it's not out
of fear it's out of an understanding of
science and logic it's a logical
criticism not a fear-based one
and also frankly observing
that um a male
with long hair is not a woman that's not
bigotry
even if it's hypocritical coming from
jimmy kimmel it's still not bigotry
so i'm not going to say that it is
even an attempt to score a point against
jimmy kimmel because you're not going to
score the point then
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated